[Music]
so we'll
start
apologies
i don't know what dan's up to anybody
here from dan
conflicts of interest any conflicts
confirmation of uh minutes any issues
with regard to accuracy
somebody prepared to move
move council williams seconded council
award put it always in favor please say
aye
against carried matters rising
none
we have no reputations presentations
we've gone to reports 5.1 sophie
so i have a report today which is an
update from a report presented at the
unr meeting in february about the
stormwater network discharge consents
so it's a report for information with a
bit of an update of how it is going with
the
interpretation of the consent conditions
following the granting of the
consent for rangiwara in may
and so a little bit of analysis about
what's one of the work programs that are
required from those consent conditions
this this
the implementation of the network
discharge consents involves many
departments across council
and
so the analysis
of the work programs has been quite
interesting just to see how it reaches
through
you have to quite a few departments and
looking at
capabilities and resourcing from
different departments we have
established a project control group
which has met
twice
and that will continue to meet quarterly
with the intention of reporting coming
through to this committee
uh yeah happy to take any questions
particularly around the analysis of the
work programs or the memo that was
attached with the contaminant load model
that's proposed rangiora
thank you members got any questions
council stuart
um
bearing in mind your excellent summary
of pc7
is this consent called in in 2024 for
under that consent
review
i believe the consent reviews under pc7
are only for stream depleting takes and
uh
yeah so i don't believe this consent
would be called in for review um but
that's something i can i can double
check for your counsellor
thank yep we've got a recommendation
somebody prepared to move
council williams
seeking the council of blacky council
williams
no i think it's all on the report so
thank you
council black is all good anybody else
i'll put it all those in favor please
say hi
again
carried
takes us 5.2 sophie again
another report for information regarding
saturn tools and an oil spill event in
march which was linked to certain tools
although there have been previous oil
spills that might have been uh but
unsubstantiated by ecan to be related
so the proposal the report goes through
the proposal of how
we have worked with environment
canterbury to
establish who
whether as a medium risk site that then
falls under our network discharge
consents or whether it's a high-risk
site that is then covered by a discharge
consent by environment canterbury which
is indeed what's been resolved and
there's a little bit of information in
the report about the
work from certain tools to
improve their stormwater
management on site and and by our
council to improve the system downstream
as well
happy to take questions
members got any questions council
williams
there would have been a cost with a lot
of staff time on this um did sutton
tools get an invoice
for that
yeah so there has been some time by greg
bennett and myself
to
to investigate whether it was high risk
or medium risk and it is something i
have asked with environment canterbury
is something that we actually need to
proactively front foot to not
have this confusion um in the future
but it's not something that both greg
bennett and myself are not in um cost
recoverable roles in in the three waters
team we we do respond to
to issues like this and he can have been
taking a lead in the investigation
so certain tools have not been sent an
invoice by
wdc the question would be should we be
involved in a charge if there's a
discharge like that that affects our
waterways
to the people responsible for
discharging
so under the network discharge consensus
if another high risk site won't be until
2025 but
um and also there's the three waters
reformed so the water services entity in
the future has a process to exclude
certain tools if they don't
meet water standards water quality
standards set in the network discharge
consent so that's the process
we do also we are setting
pollution prevention plan approvals fees
but that will be next financial year so
that because the consent was granted
this year for rangiora we don't even
have the kai point consent yet
we haven't set fees and charges for that
monitoring of those pollution prevention
plans
and there will always be a bit of a
delay until we get those those fees and
charges in place to be our charge
okay so let's do it
thank you i noticed that on page under
long-term management you talk about e2
environmental
preparing um
helping suttons with their um
uh with their consent application have
you got a time frame for
for when
this is all going to happen
uh so i think e2 environmental have
already had um they've already taken
undertaking some
sampling at the site and have we've met
to look at the proposal of what they
have what
oil separator and
gross pollutant filter they're looking
at installing but i haven't seen their
store in a management plan
and we have agreed that they will
give that to the council before the
consent is application is lodged but
there's no time frame from our council
that we've set with them it would be
uh you can i believe has set a time
frame but i'm not sure what that is
we're concerned about this
um
uh what else i was gonna ask something
else i've forgotten now it's all right
any further questions
got some recommendations there oh sorry
just remember um
so
the
the um mitigation that's in the sump uh
in the downstream pipe that's all clean
and you know in the interim now before
any upgrade
we're quite confident that no nothing is
going to get past that sump barrier and
the pipe down to the cam is clean
i wouldn't say that it's a hundred
percent
certain that we have there are
mitigations in place but i think if
there was
a significant spill of of oil um
the the
filter that's in there is is would not
be sufficient um so i think the oil
separator that's been proposed it would
be much more
it is they are interim measures
and it is something that one of the
reasons that the
sutton tools was to find the high risk
site is that we realize just the
quantity of oil they are using is about
30 to 30 000 20 to 30 000 liters
circulating in a
pump around the pro like constantly
being circulated with their their
cutting tool machines
and um they also do have a large tank of
diesel stored on the property that's
probably about 10 000 liters so the
volumes of that amount of
chemical there's there's always yeah i
think they do need to think about the
risks a little bit more for how they
can can mitigate anything
serious
another question of either sophie or
jared is is
how how comfortable are we
with this interim arrangement
because because
this issue's come before the zone
committee many many times where a slick
has been downstream in the
in the cam river
and
i was hopeful that you know the
attention would be
absolutely robust and watertight
um
even on an interim basis but doesn't
look like perhaps it would be
and so how comfortable are we that that
um this is going to
or should we be taking further action in
the interim um to prevent any of
a discharge into the river
we're not as comfortable as we would
like to be as is the answer
and
i think the approach we're taking is
appropriate at this stage so we are um i
think that
as long as we're actively monitoring
um uh and making sure
that we keep our communication with
environment canterbury and certain tools
and
um i think if there hasn't been any
action um
then we need to maybe escalate it at
that stage so i think you know it's not
ideal but um
there have been some interim measures
put in on site um
and
it's you know
it's i think pretty much as sophie
described it's
we're not 100 comfortable but um and and
i think once they've got a good system
set up then we'd be able to take a more
hands-off approach in the future
councilworking
here at all sophie do you know
how did the oil actually physically get
into the sun do we know
what happened
so i've heard of a couple different
pathways
i definitely there's tracking by the
forklifts that go in and out so the oil
vaporizes volatiles and and then
comes becomes attached to surfaces
and then when the forklift goes in and
out it's going through water and then
so there's there's quite a bit through
that tracking uh
these there was also a report um from a
room employee that one of the barrels
overflowed that was stored outside
um so i think there are a couple of
different ways that the that oil has
been escaping but just the fact that it
does collect onto surfaces it's not just
in the in the barrels and in within the
the circulation of the oil it's it's
getting out and it was also going
through the extractor fans onto the roof
i believe
so i think there have been improvements
to the the extractor fan system as well
as the tracking so there yeah there have
been multi multiple
facets they've been tackling but uh it's
yeah it's um
it's the property of the oil is that it
does spread um
through the air
council of wood
obviously this is a
real concern and it's been ongoing and
could we
perhaps
keep monitoring it would it be advisable
to say to
sutton tools that
if they don't
comply or they create in the future
expenses with spillage that they need to
be we need to be recompensed for the
costs for the cleanup
yeah well i think sophie touched on that
earlier we're going to bring in a
similar process to here and right here
and then fees and charges and i'm
assuming that'll go through the um
annual plan through marie harrison
yes so we have put some
fees in charge after visa charges that
will be in the drainage commentary but
also been liaising with marie harris
around that could i
suggest that that's explained
and documented very clearly to certain
tools that you know we're very concerned
in any future um spillages um
we will be charging you for the cleanup
and there could be a fine as well
no further questions we've got a
recommendation
i'm going to move it council award
moved second to council of blacky
councilwood
um i i think that
it is this is a really sort of serious
ongoing issue
that needs to be addressed a big enough
company that needs to have better
controls of of what's happening and um
so i think that we need to sort of make
it very clear that what's been happening
is not
not acceptable and
we need to really get on top of this
issue
council becky
any other members
council
stuart yes i'll support this
and it's
as councillor woods said it's been an
ongoing issue
reported to the
zone committee many times
it looks like it's a fairly ubiquitous
problem across the site being um
you know substandard really the um
pollution control
i would personally like to see um
some sort of time frame on
um
a more permanent solution
port but i realized that it's it is
monitoring is ongoing with ecan and wdc
and the companies
obviously recognizing that there is a an
issue
but
i don't want to be around the zone
committee table and have mike bait come
again and say with pictures of oil slick
it comes out behind the um
behind the kaiapoi mill into the river
just um upstream of the confluence with
the um kaiapoi
so at its worst it heads down um
it heads down into the into the
town or at least in the
um at the confluence so it's it's um
quite visible
in the urban area
it can be so really
do support
quite a rigorous and robust
monitoring of the issue and all
encouragement to sutton's to get on with
the job
thank you
council williams
yeah i'm a little concerned when we just
got mentioned that the forklift running
through the soil
um creating it into our storm waters
surely
when it's not damp
all that oil will be leaking through the
ground into
virtually
potable drinking water into wells in the
area
and what have you so
i think we need to approach them about
um
if they've got thoughtless driving
through oil
um it shouldn't really have a forklift
driving through oil or that continually
so maybe they need a um
some catchment for the oil
excesses um before we can get to a
forklift or to the ground that sound
like it
you know going to the normal soil as
well
i believe they now have daily floor
cleans to try to avoid that so that that
was so that tracking was a pro problem
they identified previous from previous
times yeah so
they have cdx3 has been a lot easier to
work that the work environment is a lot
better since they've made some of these
improvements
um just for the workers to be not
walking around an oily oily floor
yeah
um
maybe kelly simpson might better inform
me but i don't believe
we're really injecting that inspecting
something we do have we have been a
couple of times to look um but not not
on a regular maintenance schedule to see
how that um what is what is in there
the only other thing i was going to add
is part of
our minor stormwater improvement works
in kaiapoi
this financial year we're going to look
at making some modifications within the
kaiapoi domain so that's downstream of
the site which will actually mean we've
got a dedicated sampling point for
discharge from the site so that would be
in the off-site and independent of what
they do
it will also provide us with a chamber
that if we have any concerns with what's
being discharged we can actually
block it off and i completely isolate it
from the public stormwater network
and
instruct certain tools to undertake
remedial works
so it's something we haven't been
actively monitoring in the past but now
we know what we know
uh we're doing some works to make sure
we can keep a closer night on the
situation
um just to pick up on another part of
the question about the potential risk to
our potable water supplies
so
the nearest wells are at the darnley
waterhead works and also the smith
street well field so that's for both
rangiora and kaiapoi's water supplies
they are quite some distance from this
site and they also are
artesian or
semi-artesian
and
they are protected by
quite a number you know just by the
strata of the land underneath the ground
so it would be an extremely remote risk
that any activity that happened on
sudden tools could have an impact on our
water supplies
we would see
where we see it as in the surface water
and it is visible
fortunately oil actually
is pretty visible
you know even in quite small quantities
you get that
it becomes visible on the
in the waterway so
we're it's a good question to ask um but
we've got a i think we've got a very
high level of protection for the potable
water supply this is more about the
impact of surface water that's a concern
any further question
just one further point of that's all
right
um so the network discharge consent
monitoring programs also have a
monitoring site downstream at the mill
kaiko mill which
is judas commence any time um when we
get the water unit have the bottles
ready to go and that will be quarterly
that we will be sampling from from the
sump so that is
something that we also have ongoing
from for that to monitor
reply
um yes um i think that this is 2021 and
um
i think that that
needs to be tighter control i i'm having
disquiet when they said barrels
leak over or come over i this sloppy
work that's sloppy
i just don't can't understand that
and think that um
i would also like to see if we're only
doing quarterly
at the back of the woolen mills um
checks i think we should be doing
monthly so we have tota
much more um
feedback
about what's actually happening on site
so that we can attack
or consult with them quicker if there's
anything that's malpractice that's not
happening that they just keep them on
their toes i think this is
really you know this oil is really of a
grave concern and the volumes of all
that they need for their tools
50 000
liters which is a lot of oil we wouldn't
want to have
a complete disaster there
so i put it all those in favor please
say aye
against
it's carried
so we've gone to 5.3
and jump in
um thank you so this report
sorry
all right
okay sorry this report is to present the
wakakotahi technical audit to the unr
committee
the audit process is to provide
assurance
to wakakotahi of the investment that the
investment is providing
a delivering value for money
and the audit did find that generally
the network was in good condition here
in waimakari
this is the first audit that's been
completed since 2013.
the audit did present nine
recommendations
and 12
suggestions for improvement
these have been included into appendix 2
in the action plan
and also included in that is a time
frame for delivery of these actions
of these items can be delivered in the
short term while others
such as prioritizing and upgrading
bridge approach guard rails
will require time and funding to be able
to roll these out
i'm happy to take any questions
questions
counselor duty
oh okay
thank you
um just with the costings of having to
do these guard rails and then the other
uh things that they're asking you to do
such as
tidying up the seal
um
the um
the shoulders higher and things like
that so some of that stuff respect to
the
higher road uh shoulders they can be
addressed by the
by the team at the moment can't they
so some of the items we can address as
part of our general maintenance work um
high shoulder is one of those things
that we have developed a program and
we'll work through
and that will require that will be
funded from our maintenance budgets over
a number of years
things that are new improvements such as
upgrades to things like the guard rails
or additional signage at intersections
will need to be included into our future
programs and funding sort from nzta for
that
so the other question i was going to ask
which you've just slightly highlighted
on is about
signage and such like good visible
signage at crossroads and
such like so is there any other way
apart from signage can you do
road markings to say like giveaway or
something on the road markings or stop
or something just to
perhaps help alleviate the problem until
such
you've got time and money to do the
other
the other
options
yeah marking giveaway on the road
um
it really needs so there are rules
around where that can actually go and it
has to be within the set distance of the
intersection
so
that is um
i guess that's fairly well set but what
we
are going to look at and i guess a
little bit and
uh
i guess further to the res the accident
uh crash that happened at the weekend
is we will be looking to develop a bit a
strategy for how we want to manage our
crossroads going forward because
obviously they are a high risk for us in
the district
and we'll look at whether there are any
other interventions that can be put in
place
generally what has happened in the
past is we've put the advanced
intersection ahead warning in
on a number of our higher risk
intersections
um
but we don't have that for every single
intersection through the district
there's probably an argument for whether
that's actually necessary at every
single intersection so that's got to be
part of the assessment and
prioritization process to make sure
we're identifying and addressing our
worst intersections
um but yeah it's it's very challenging
with that flat grid-like
district
so my last one is so you'll prioritize
the roads that are most heavily used
first
um
and the other thing is
how can you manage with the sun strike
sun strike unfortunately is one of those
things that we really struggle there's
no magic fix
um unfortunately to sun strike other
than just i guess still trying to make
sure we've got that advanced warning in
place
we will have a look and see whether
there are other any new techniques or
different ways of managing
it could be maybe some rumble strips
into intersections or those sort of
things to be able to
highlight intersections ahead on roads
which suffer from southern strike as an
issue
but again it's how it's balancing that
expenditure and which roads we do it on
and which ones we don't so there'll be
part of that
developing a list of
interventions
and determining where they need to go
thank you very much
williams
yeah considering we have an awful lot of
complaints about gravel roads
roundabouts needed deaths and on our
roads and waimakariri
do we accept and note b that the
wakataki technical audit report
summarise that the road network is in
generally good condition
when we're being told by our ratepayers
and others
that it's not do we accept the report
um yes i do accept that report and i
think these so the auditors
travel around the country auditing the
different networks
obviously when they're here it's a
snapshot in time and they were here in
march um
we were here we're in a period of
settled weather and
the observation of the network was that
it was in good condition
um we struggle at times with our
unsealed roads
so in the likes of may with the flood
events and whenever we have those
periods of long and high
quantities of rain we have issues with
our unsealed roads so
um yes i think this is a an appropriate
snapshot of what we had at the time
just probably further
as you'll be aware councillor williams
we do present you with the
information that shows
the uh things like the road
roughness survey information
as that's done and
that
stacked up against other councils around
the country including our peer group
and
so based on that information this
technical report does reinforce that
view one of the things with
no matter what road network you've got
you will always have complaints and
for example a reseal
you know whatever your cycle is so it's
15 years of
reseal cycle you're always going to have
1 15th of your network as due for its
reseal in that year leading up to it
so and same with grading as soon as the
road has been graded it's going to start
to deteriorate
and so there's all and people do have
different levels of expectations um
and
and i think unfortunately
they uh
you know that does get that you know you
build a picture because we do get a lot
of service requests and you get a lot of
contact from the community um but when
we actually stand back and look at the
measurable information
i think that you we do support that look
in saying that it's hugely challenging
for us we're really um you know we're
not going to say
we've got adequate resource and we've
got adequate funding and we're 100 happy
um we have had our bid knocked back from
wakakotahi
and the bid that we put up we believe
was
bare bones basically
and
we do have challenges um
you uh you know as you'll be aware
things like um to get going and carry
out significant interventions on things
like high shoulders can become very
expensive getting some really good
pavement rehabilitation again very
expensive so they're always a is a
trade-off in terms of cost
so
yes we accept that but i think we just
do have to accept the report as it is
presented to us
but we really do
agree and acknowledge that it's a huge
challenge trying to get the keep on top
of that network and it's becoming more
and more difficult and the funding is
definitely not keeping up with
growth and inflation and those two when
they start compounding year on year
are really challenging and
the picture going forward um is not
getting any better so
the funding source for uh
from wakakata is based on road user
charges and fuel taxes
and
that's going down rather than up
and the demand on the network is going
up so
it's going to continue to be a challenge
in the future
where i was actually coming from from
that question was they actually fund us
by the 51
and it's really good for them
to give a report saying our roads are
really good
because if and if we don't argue with
that situation saying we need more
funding because we don't think they're
up to the standards their rate parts
want
there's a good chance we'll get less
funding from it because
we're agreeing with him on the report we
are
i get around quite a lot of the roads
and um
i don't agree that our roads are
generally in really good condition
particularly on the shoulders on some of
them and whatever so that that was where
my question was coming from
um should we
accept the report as in good condition
that was all
right no further questions we've got a
recommendation somebody prepared to move
i'll move from the chair somebody
prepared a second second and counselor
blackie
thank you um some good points have uh
have been made all through the questions
and quite
not such a question
um i agree that we do have to accept
this this report and uh and on the basis
so as you know as you know i've just
moved it that's all i've got to say
council blackie
any other comments
put out all those in favor please say
aye
gates
carried
so we'll move on to 5.4 kitty
can
now we're cooking with gas
okay
so i'm basically asking that the
utilities and rating committee
delegates authority to approve the final
submission on the waste strategy and
legislation consultation documentation
to mere gordon and to councillor brian
there is one change i would like to make
to the recommendation be
as they have actually extended the
deadline for the
consultation to the 10th of december
that gives us a bit more time to come up
with the submission but it's still
outside the council
schedules
i'm happy to take questions
questions
no questions somebody prepared to move
with that alteration to to be to reflect
10th of december
move councillor williams seconded
me gordon council williams
i think it's um self-explanatory thank
you
thank you kitty
so we've got reports
and we confirm this one from the
ranger community board
you're gonna speak to that and you just
see any need to speak to it
um
joanne did you yep
thank you um so as mentioned this report
has previously been through the rain or
ashley community board and is seeking
approval for no stopping on charles
upham drive
our staff have been working with ryman's
on the subject of parking on charles
upham drive and particularly around
concerns from the residents exiting the
driveways on the western side of the
road around the apartments
so there are some recommended changes to
the no stopping
in that area to ensure there is
sufficient visibility and also to tidy
up some of the no stopping along the
road which hadn't previously been
approved happy to take any questions
members got questions
thanks to duty thank you just um with
going in there occasionally um
it's find it very difficult to actually
find somewhere where you can park the
car so
with and i'm i'm one of those ones that
used to use that western area as you're
coming into things but when we're doing
jp training and um so we're
you know we're uh i'm just
nowhere on earth we can park then if
that's the case
yeah so there will still be parking on
the road um it wall it's so at the
southern end of charles up drive it is
will be on the
right hand side of the road as you head
north and then outside the apartments on
the left hand side and then further up
again on the right we are and i guess
we'll keep that dialogue open with
ryman as well and encouraging their part
staff to park further away to be able to
allow visitor parking as well
it just helps free up that space on road
but so yes it is challenging around
there and they do have a number of staff
that are parking and walking into
the village but there's also a number of
residents in the apartments who are
parking their private cars on the road
as well so it's a combination of both
any further questions
somebody you got a question councilwood
um just well just an idea i wondered
whether
some part of it
in that case should there be to to
provide for visitor parking whether
there should be a two-hour parking for
some of those car parks so that visitors
can park but just to
park just an idea
so that's not something that has been
requested at this stage i think there is
a little bit of visitor parking within
the area immediately in front of the
three street horseroad ryman building
and i think there are one or two visitor
car parks under the apartments but
there's not a huge amount
i guess my observation from the times
i've been up here and dan may have a
comment on this i know he's visited a
few times as he generally can find a
park on the road but
there's not
abundant supply they are
limited
emily gordon was it a question were you
going to move
any other questions
you got a question
okay move me and gordon second
um counselors
i just firstly say and thanks jamin and
team this has been a large amount of
work over a long period of time
i i know this is not going to please
everyone but you've certainly gone the
best way to finding
the best resolutions here so
that's all we can expect
there is parking issues down at ryman um
because of staff
and the fact that there isn't and also
because residents have more than one car
some don't want to accept the path part
of the problem but they've come there
with more than one
vehicle and also don't really want to
purchase a garage so it's just the way
in which some of that
has worked out but in general terms we
i understand our staff will push pretty
extensively
around
the road wits and everything else with
design and traffic engineers in an ideal
world there would be more parking
provided
there than there is currently but it's
just not how the how the rules work and
in fact even even now so we have to
we can't take into account purely
parking either so it's not an easy
situation but i think where we've got to
here i think the staff have done a
really good job of trying to come up
with a really a viable a really good
solution that will work for the majority
bear in mind that we've also done work
out at the intersection and made changes
out there in consultation with residents
there's a bus
stop
location
out there as well which is pleased a lot
and then time
when
charles up and drive does open up and
link through with huntington in that
area in arlington which is underway the
working with that that's going to
improve the flow and and maybe the bus
in time when we do another review and
and time will be able to come through
and come close closer to the charles up
from itself which would
in itself please a number of residents
as well um i go down there quite
regularly because i'm summonsed or what
happens it's the wrong term ask down to
come and talk predominant issues are
eroding um and joanne knows because she
often comes down with me so
these things here will be a means that
we can feedback that we have followed
through and i think shane and the team
have done a really good job so thanks
joey
council williams
yeah while supporting us because it's
helping um sort out ryman's problems i
just hope
we're not pushing the the problem
further down the road into some of the
um non-ryman residence houses and all of
a sudden they're going to get car
parking problems outside their places
because their visitors can't come and
visit them so
that's my only concern with a whole lot
but
um
supporting this side but
i
don't think i would look forward to
some um delegations from some other
property owners coming here saying we've
pushed the problem down to their place
which i would not be surprised what will
happen
any other comments
you want to reply me gordon
i'll put it all those in favor please
say aye
those against
carried
so we come up to uh matters for
information seven point one through to
seven point five somebody prepared to
move
me with councillor williams second of
mayor gordon
any comments
i'll put it always in favor please say
those against
carried
portfolio updates 8.1 council williams
oh i thought sorry i thought
i think 7.12 to 7.5
we're just receiving information
the new pedestrian refuge has been
installed in township road outside tmro
school
to assist the school crossing
that way am i too noisy am i
sorry
um the windows contributing to um
continue to be in uses with staff
keeping an eye on trees around the
district um
today there's been a bit of wind just
today um the reselling program is
underway um and some reseal repairs
being undertaken
the
footpath renewals program is underway
with the footpath along east belt being
reconstructed
and maintenance respears on northern
side of kippenberger avenue where tree
roots are pushed up the footpaths
creating hazards uh getting sorted
um
we all know sadly there's a fatal
another fatal on the south south here
burnt hill road um
it's a bit of a concern what's happening
around the um
area with all these fatals we're having
lately
just seemed to coming all the time so
but i just don't think there's anything
we can do about it just
one of those things that happens so and
it's really about it for roading
council stuart
thank you um
long-awaited pc7 is out and um sophie
allen has helpfully um
did that email go out to everybody
no bullet points it's just a
draft but the intention is that we will
give some advice to
the rest of the councillors it just
means a portfolio holder okay
yeah
um
yes well it's it's out as a document it
is considered by ecan at an
extraordinary meeting tomorrow
um thursday thursday
um yes so um
that um the stock water by-law that we
took um submissions on last month i
think was a month before
was waiting yeah what
was waiting for pc7 to come out so to
just try and integrate what we were
doing and and what implications pc7 has
for the stock water um
race i see my own submission to exclude
horses was not supported by the panel
but however
all other stock apart from sheep
are out
and artificial waterways are now covered
that's that i did find
um it's thousands of pages that
that decision um
yes so that would be
we're expecting then to reconvene after
a heads up from staff and um looking to
have the stock water race bylaw back in
front of
unr or the council
in december
drainage i can't think of a single drain
that i'm upset about at the moment but
uh yeah
thank you
though kelly might have something
yes so that's about it thank you
councillor williams
um on the sewage side it's um pleasant
to report now
we
we were getting some plants by some of
our trees from a
wooden
treatment station
shading some houses there so
they've now been removed and
they will
um
the house is getting a bit more sunshine
now than they used to get
um the gary meer water safety plan was
approved by the ministry of health last
week
this is the first of our water supplies
to have a water safety plan approved
under the new framework which is good
but as of monday the 15th of november
the new water regulator has taken over
from the ministry health
and
they'll be reviewing reviewing our
drinking water safety plans
in the future um the fluoridation bill
uh will shortly come into force um
we come in on monday the 15th of
um
november um it gives the director of
health direct um
local authorities to fluoridate their
water supplies
and
the first step from the director of
health is to invite local authorities to
comment on the cost
of fluoridating and when they can
implement fluoridation by so
it reads to me it doesn't look like
we're going to have an option
um
council staff have obtained some advice
on the cost of fluoridating its water
supplies but we'll look at getting this
updated um
i don't know whether kelly could um
comment whether
we're expected to pay for the
fluoridation
systems or
will the ministry or the ministry of
health
help pay for that or is it directly on
the councils
they have indicated in the information
they've published is that there will be
some funding available for capital works
but not for
ongoing operational costs
um
i'm not sure if we would meet the
criteria to qualify for any other
capital works funding so
at the moment we're expecting that we
would bear the costs of implementing
them
the other thing that feeds into this is
time frames
that we would be imposed to look at
imposed on us to implement fluoridation
and it's going to get pretty close to
2024 by
which time we can actually do this which
is getting very close to when the water
service entities time frame that's been
announced by
central government as well so there's
that lens coming into it as well
yeah thank you for that i'm still
confident that we're still going to
control our water that's all
uh solid waste which is uh which is me
and i guess
a bigger issue at the moment um
most of you will be aware that there
have been complaints uh with regard to
the imperial appearance and tidiness
uh down at rangara
jared has has been out
to to have a look
and um
in our pre-meeting this morning
he's exploring
some options
including getting a higher level of
waste management involved in
regular
meetings
the other option is
that you know we look at perhaps
bringing
the tidiness of the site
uh more in-house because we have got
contractors who do very good jobs as far
as our streetscapes and parks and what
have you is concerned and
whether there's the possibility of
extending their expertise
actually into the transfer station
um so
yeah there's a bit of water to go under
this this bridge
but nevertheless
you know i've expressed concern i know
uh the mayor
councillor williams certainly has and
we've had feedback and i completely
agree that um
some work needed to be done down there
too to improve the appearance of
rather a key asset
and a lot of our customers
use said asset so it needs to look as
good as it can be
lumping all this in of course most of
you are on the side and hazardous waste
committee
we are looking at
redesigning the site
so
appearance will certainly play a key
part
in that redesign as well so
there's work on that and that's about
all i've got to report on you've got a
question for me councilwombs
your question for jared polin um
how did the site get as bad as that when
12 months ago the same complaints and we
had a council inspection there
are we not
keeping an eye on the condition of that
site for it to get so bad in the first
place
um i think
i think the short answer is no we're not
keeping an adequate
eye on it in there so i've been involved
as councillor brian um
talked about in a pretty thorough audit
of the site
i have also
had a look at the contract
what the requirements are under the
contract what our
our own inspections
regime is like and
so
i think on all in all of those areas
there's some issues that we need to
follow up um i'm happy to just say look
and i'm pursuing that with our staff and
through the contract so um how did it
get to that
um state we've had
uh i think it's probably fair say we
haven't given it the focus that we
should have been through the contract
and we're in the process of rectifying
that
thank you just on transport last
week as some of you will recall we
did mention that we got an engagement
with nicole rosie who's the chief
executive of
nzta
i was joined at the discussion along
with the chief executive and also
jared and appreciate jared for the
preparation that had gone in beforehand
in the presentation that we
did present to nicole
she was left to know
no doubt really what our priorities were
in our expectations
i just hope that what in safety
improvements which was with the
predominant reason for the discussion
um that the the mistake that apparently
did occur is a genuine one and uh that
we are able to
see that funding restored so they have
taken that on board
and there was some other issues to do
with the tuahiri footpath which
appears that they will support uh being
funded so we were just awaiting how that
will
shape and that was something that we had
raised we also raised issues of
skewbridge
um the um point of the barrier wide rope
barrier down the motorway and you know
the perception certainly from our uh and
the ratepayers and certainly our local
police because i know they have
certainly said that to me is that there
hasn't been a crash down there and can't
see the the real need when really the
need is further along
um through one end so that was a really
good discussion that we had with nicole
and i if i
compare that to 12 to 18 months ago when
she presented i found someone that was
much more on top of her
portfolio than she was before and if i
did say she was
listening um would be the term because
the previous time i know a number of
mayors and counselors attended that
forum weren't as impressed and i
certainly was with her and her
genuineness and the
uh i think
challenge immense challenges she's got
in that portfolio that was the first of
three meetings with her that day
we rolled onto canterbury mural forum
and then the greater christchurch
partnership so by the end of it she was
really clear had a clear picture of
where
um the transport priorities are not only
for our district but for canterbury and
the greater christchurch
area
last yesterday morning and last night
councilor williams and myself
attended a couple of meetings with
around the southbrook improvements
and that was a really good engagement
that our staff had organised actually we
had some robust feedback from businesses
that disappeared to say
council williams
and so that's that's all part of it you
know in terms of the proposed lights um
down there but general general
acceptance from the second grouping with
residents
of how well thought through and
appreciate appreciative they were
that
things had been considered through south
brock particularly for their homes and
more broadly
around buckley's road and the proposed
improvements through the year
um
the second part of the weekend group
which
council williams myself and um
jim jarrett are on is to consider the uh
the next part of that process which is
works underway with bypass
improvements through woody and
critically and fernside flex scenario
which are going to improve well
hopefully over time
well i'm
finding improvements through there
there's no one single magic wallet and
we know that
but there's a there is a process to
evaluate and go through that so i'm
looking forward to that next part of the
process but i was genuinely pleased with
the engagement we had yesterday and the
feedback and
all our staff to the team did an
excellent job
explaining and being very patient with
as i said some fairly robust feedback at
times they excelled and did really well
on that for him so that's good thank you
well it was indicated to uh on a number
of occasions that the
it had it had been planned to be
included within the budget and as they
went out for the
funding of the nltp there's a lot of
pressures on that so the advice we've
had back from some nzta
officials is that a mistake had been
made and that not being included
so
we're just waiting now to see how that
will be remedied um
there will be
some
have to be as a consequence of that some
re-prioritization
of that so we're waiting to hear where
that will be but we either genuine
there's a genuineness there
uh that you know um
they acknowledged that there were some
we had some certain commitments given to
us and undertakings
but until it's unlike a might it's very
hard to see that realized so
they got the message really strongly
that we do want to see those
improvements implemented as has been
promised so
we will do a follow-up later to that
effect and keep the pressure on because
it's been a long time waiting for that
community and for all our community
there including
ravenswood
pegasus
and the solution there across the road
whether it's an underpass arrangement or
a safer arrangement through the earlier
certainty of acknowledgment and we've
got to do a bit more on that to build a
case for that investment but
uh the one around the the other safety
improvements that have been indicated
the roundabout of woody end and some
other
um
measures that have been um discussed are
the ones that principally were after
being uh implemented as soon as possible
so i have no questions
no urgent general um
i just
i just wondered if i've been thinking
about
um the sutton
tall people
what is happening if they happen to have
a big fire there
and that oil is all very volatile and
there's so much of it and they get
spillages and there's a fire is is there
a safety
um precautions there to stop what i
suggest you do
is
type that out in an email right and send
it through to probably jared who's
putting it on to surgery i think that's
the best way because otherwise we're
going to get
quite it's just a thought and i'd just
like to bring it up has it been
considered it's a good question and i
think yeah if you flick it through in an
email
and um
because it's not quite the forum
at the moment it's a good question
um
so we're going to public excluded i'll
move from the chair seconded
council ward put it all those in favor
please say aye
those against carried so we've got two
there's no minute it's very good